[Music]
[Applause]
okay this is where we take videos of
famous people and we combine them
usually for no good reason
it kills time first up we've builded I'm
not kidding please builded Brad Pitt and
Angelina Jolie why not let's see what
happens
[Music]
still beautiful yeah it is sexy yeah
alright it's time to blend two other
celebrities Steven Seagal and Selena
Gomez I mean to be honest I am kind of
on the fence now because even the people
that are opposing Obama are not
necessarily you know
in my opinion mama June and Nicholas
Cage
and I telescope to remind folks that I
could also do minimalistic more
docudrama more cinema Barrett a photo
realistic acting as well and finally you
asked for it we're providing it Gary
Busey and Yoda with the dog male dog
this hopeful the female dog lady look in
the mirror over backwards and that way
he'll mount the right side of her to
bring in little puppy babies
[Applause]
I love the new Yoda you don't know what
he's gonna say